Here's a beautiful, soft trim that
can be used as a hem or a band.
It's easy and it can be worked at any
gauge on any machine with any stitch
pattern.
Adding a unique touch
to your next project.
It also lays fairly flat
right off the machine.
Taming that dreaded stockinette curl.
It's a good option to replace ribbing.
Get started by casting on with waste yarn
and Ravel cord to make it even faster.
You might consider using a
cast on rag and Ravel cord.
We're going to be forming a small
hem, so this step is not optional.
Knit five rows, hang
your cast on stitches.
And knit one row at one
number looser tension.
Change back to your band tension.
Set your machine to hold.
Pull out every nine needles.
I'm using the Knit it Now cheat sheets to
select my needles so I don't have to count
all the way across the bed.
Why nine needles?
Well, do your own thing
here in this photo.
The scallops line up with the stitch
pattern, so figure out how many needles
and how wide your
scallops are going to be.
While holding these stitches.
Slowly knit a few rows.
As you knit, you'll see the loops
building up on the held needles.
This is forming the scallops.
Watch the hooks on either side of those
held needles and make sure the stitches
don't pop off.
Putting a little weight
on each scallop helps.
You might want to pull the needles on each
side of those held needles out a bit to
make the knitting easier.
Use your judgment here.
The pattern says to knit eight rows with
this thick yarn, I'm using, eight rows
were just too many.
When you're ready to finish the scallop,
turn off the hold setting and slowly,
carefully knit across all the stitches
and confirm that everything knit properly.
Remove any excess weight, switch to your
stitch pattern if you're using one and
continue knitting your garment
to use this technique as a band,
knit across all the stitches
to form the scallops
knit.
One more row.
I like to do this to be safe and remove
the work on waste yarn or a garter bar.
Hang your garment in the needles, pushing
the work back all the way past those
needle latches.
Then hang the stitches of your
band in the hooks of the needles.
Close the latches and pull the stitches
through the garment pickup edge.
Just bind off with the
method of your choice.
I like to use a back stitch bind off.
It's neat and tidy and almost
impossible to work too tightly.
Add some in the in-the-ditch button holes
and you've got a really pretty finish.
For your new cardigan.
Thank you for watching.
Look for other buttonhole and band
techniques in the learning library.
Subscribers have full access to hundreds
of tutorials on a wide variety of topics
and all skill levels.
Please consider becoming a subscriber.
Happy knitting.